leïla bekhti venez avec moi de seconde
pour rester ici un ou le bouscat leïla
vous m'avez des filles au ping pong
alors je vous le dis leïla si je gagne
vous devrez vous devrez parler de moi si
vous avez un autre césar d'accord
pendant les remerciements
voilà et si vous gagnez tous les jours
tous les jours toutes les émissions que
je ferai à vie je remercierai leïla
bekhti à la fin en deux points
ok on y va en deux points c'est parti
c'est bon vincent aux copines ou chanter
quelque chose pour 1,29 alors qu'on joue
s'il vous plaît un nom comme quoi ce que
vous voulez en italien une calzone pas
adlib on y va je le ferai j'ai vu le
niveau je vais jouer de la main gauche
d'accord la malaysie servir je joue de
la magouille c'est parti ça fait un
point c'est en deux points
j'espère qu'ils y voilà enfin troisième
point la main gauche allez si c'est
gagné j'espère qu'elle va avoir un césar
la petite mer voilà ça c'est fait et
ouais faut courir
attention c'est la balle de match je la
joue de la main gauche
c'est parti et un peu de la main droite
je verrai je vais je vais switcher est
mais pour qui se prend
ça il ya une nouvelle règle qui dit ça
pour toi mais casser sa cote passer que
si ses cachets à l'est du rhône retard
tout ça joue maintenant c'est beau très
bien joué la main droite match en main
droite c'est dégueulasse bah je suis là
mon salon et tout bas alors moche au
basket et à vasini ce match m'a dit ça
fait moins la maligne l'unc au cinoche
ces années sont obligatoires oui je
voulais me sera ma jolie ça y est le
film est sorti aujourd'hui et leïla
merci d'avoir été avec nous